Is your job about to get automated?
Yes, probably.
It's already happening in some unexpected places.
See if your occupation is safe.
In an interview last week with the American Enterprise Institute,...
...Bill Gates confirmed that yes, the rumors are true.
Robots will be taking your jobs.
Software substitution, whether it's for drivers or waiters or nurses...
...or even whatever it is you do.
But what occupations specifically are at risk?
Well, let's take a look at where some automation is already happening.
First up, you may have heard there was an earthquake in LA earlier this week.
Breaking the story unwittingly were these anchors from KTLA.
We're having an earthquake.
But the first article published about the quake...
...was actually generated by an algorithm from the LA Times,...
...plugging in just the key facts.
4.7 quake, Monday morning, Westwood, California, 6:25 AM, etc.
That robo article posted just a short few minutes after the quake...
...and the LA Times says that they use algorithms for homicides or other breaking news stories,...
...and you can probably expect this trend to continue.
But nothing can ever replace the pure sensitivity and emotion of human reporters, right?
Right?